c'est une immense fierté d'avoir été
nommé porte-parole de valérie pécresse
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a montré
ce qu'elle savait faire à la tête de la
région ile-de-france qu'elle savait
faire comme ministre et avoir le
privilège de porter sa parole pour
expliquer aux français durant les un peu
plus de trois mois que va durer cette
élection présidentielle cette campagne
ce qu'elle compte faire pour le pays
pourquoi est-ce que c'est essentiel qu
elle soit notre prochaine président de
la république c'est évidemment une
immense responsabilité ils ont suivi de
très haut niveau
un porte parole est là pour relayer les
propositions de son de sa candidate et
dans une campagne qui n'ont plus être
très courte qui je l'espère va pouvoir
quand même avoir lieu normalement avec
un débat démocratique de qualité malgré
la crise sanitaire et donc que cette
équipe de porte-parole hélas pour
démultiplier les propositions des
explications les débats afin que tous
les français connaissent la vision le
projet de valérie pécresse qui est un
projet de franche rupture et un projet
pour aller au bout des réformes dont le
pays a besoin et pour changer le
quotidien des français
[Musique]
alors trois femmes trois hommes et un
evelyne oies et j'ai cet immense
privilège d'être l'illinois de cette
équipe en l'occurrence qui est une
équipe effectivement avec un vrai
renouvellement ça ce n'est pas nouveau
jamais d'aller pécresse sa capacité à
rassembler d'abord des sensibilités très
différentes à les faire travailler
ensemble et aussi à renouveler a montré
aussi de nouveaux visages à donner sa
chance à de nouveaux profils et ça je
crois que c'est bien d'avoir à la fin
l'expérience et le renouvellement et
c'est pour cela aussi qu'elle est aussi
crédible dans cette élection
présidentielle
[Musique]